uh for you do you do like were you
always kind of like um
because you
are very good at skating Over beats that
you would not expect
women who look like you to rap over were
you always in that bag with like the
Derringer type sound or was that
something that like once you officially
came full circle signed with Griselda
that you embraced a little bit more
um because you're living in North
Carolina right now you're out in the
strip club music's a certain way so I
think
um I was doing that beforehand like
again going back to my first
um project that I ever did with buff
City it was like we was rapping over
heartbeat right so you know of course
when I moved down there it was like then
I learned how to like ride that wave so
now it's like I have an equal balance of
both and when I moved over to you know
when I actually signed to Griselda was
like you know I was excited to do it
just because there was already a lane
for me open there versus me trying to
like start off and do that by myself in
North Carolina
so I didn't walk into a pretty rabid fan
base yeah that was crazy the Griselda
fans are they're very dedicated but I
love them now at first they was a little
mean to me when I first time why were
they mean because I look like this and
they thought that I couldn't rap yeah
they probably wanted you to be like you
know
280 pounds lesbians
they wanted you to look like Queen
Latifah and set it off
right or be like super you know yeah
yeah for sure they're like yo what what
is going on with Griselda they're over
here signing pretty good right they like
is she gonna be the backup dancer oh
they only sign her because she pretty
they gonna be writing her Rhymes so like
the first Liz was me just proofing all
that [ __ ] wrong so that's why I Came Out
Swinging like I mean yeah and you did a
good job with that thank you